people are angry at steve harvey because
an old interview came out where he said
that men and women couldn't be friends
because
ultimately they're only friends because
the women
have set a precedence that we are only
friends nothing's gonna happen but the
day that you give him a chance he's
gonna try to [ __ ] you and people on
twitter aren't that's from
10 years ago years ago that's what we're
talking about it's true though
is it true i hear what he says you think
that a good looking man and a good
looking woman can be platonic friend
no no oh yeah i'm talking about
well the man yeah no matter what the if
the woman is
is is is even halfway decent the man
will
always in his mind think i can probably
try to [ __ ] her you know or i i want to
try to [ __ ]
that's just an ev i mean very let me let
me hear you let me know what you said
because automatically i'm like i'm kinda
on steve harvey's side
i don't i'm i'm incapable of that there
you go
why what do you mean well because you
know come on because you have a wife
well i have a wife and i don't i don't
really have female friends because
look okay let's get rid of this
right here okay i'm gonna tell you this
let's get rid of this right here
that you're an attractive woman there
are some guys somewhere saying yeah i'm
we're friends
no that's not true he's your friend
only because you have made it absolutely
clear
that nothing else is happening except
this friendship we have
we remain your friends in hopes that one
day
there'll be a crack in the door a [ __ ]
in the armor and trust and believe that
guy that you think is just your buddy
he will slide in that crap
he has like a million cheerleading
friends yeah because i did cheerleading
but also got to know them on a different
level right i'll be like yo i
[ __ ] can't say that's because also
you're secretly gay
that's the option of that chappelle
that's the thing dude
so yes but
a girl made it extremely clear to me
like hey we will only just be friends
you respect that boundary of course
there's a million
people out there but like but if she
never said that and you guys are friends
and both single
i would think at some point a guy's
gonna take a shot shoot a shot i'm not
saying he's a good girl for a kiss
american comes with like hey you want to
go get a drink do something
around that yeah and the same thing vice
versa a woman could be like hey do you
want to hang out it's like okay
because that's the thing is like again
in our society it's like
you can't even have a discourse now it's
like if i you know
went up to cat and we were both single
and i was like hey would you like to go
on a drink and she's like no
i respect that but nowadays it's like
even if i ask her for a drink and she's
like i felt he was
it was unwant in an unwanted advance and
he was using his power
it's like what so what am i supposed to
do then don't we're human beings we're
supposed to procreate
our brain yes you do not cross lines or
boundaries but asking out on a date it's
like
dude what do you want me to [ __ ] do
just pull my dick out i'll do it
i'm just kidding i know i wouldn't i
would when you're louis ck doug
yeah no i've never actually pulled the
only time i've ever pulled my dick out
unwanted was when i all boy catholic
high school i pulled my dick out left
and right
as soon as i was a joke don't do it i
would pull it out as a joke i've never
pulled my dick out unwanted
for to a girl i've sent understand dick
pics but it's never been my actual dick
it's
i stuffed i told the story i've stuffed
the verizon fios remote
in my sweatpants and i've sent that so
sometimes girls have been like
i'll tweet out yours
specifically
if you zoom in really quick you can see
the on off what does this look like
that remote is hot is it it's a big
remote
because now the remotes are getting
sleek this is like 2 000.
the
dude i'm talking about 2014 analog [ __ ]
yeah you don't want to toss that apple
remote yeah yeah yeah or any other dick
pic i've sent out it's been not my dick
it's just like a google image you know
so
you know my you know you once you see my
dick you know what
oh what else absolutely scarred up
score battle scars dude
stevie blue eyes is the dick pic i want
to start sending out that's the dick pic
you got to send me aaron dropped out to
me
you just got to photoshop the homer
simpson tap two out of it then yeah
then i do it absolutely
[ __ ] love stevie blue eyes how about
that when i get off stage at the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son